بين المقاومه والصمود والقمع التظاهرات
الاطول عمرا في ايران يبدو انها تنزلق
نحوهاويه مزيدا من اعمال العنف المشهد
المحتدم اثار قلق الدول الغربيه لكن اكثر
ما حذر منهم محللون سياسيون هو لهجه
النظام الايراني ايذاءا اعمال العنف التي
رافقت الاحتجاجات باتت عذرا له مستغلا
هجومي
البلاد لتوجيه اصابع الاتهام لاسرائيل
وحلفائها في الغرب بتخطيط لحرب اهليه في
ايران وتفكها
الاستراتيجيه التي تتبعها ايران اذا
تصاعدي نبره الشارع معها وتعمق رغبته
بالتغيير اوجدت قلقه لدى النظام من فقدانه
السيطره على المشهد لذا باتت السلطات
الايرانيه تبحث عن اعذار في مواجهه الرفض
المتنمي لها حسب محللين
وتفتح الباب امام ارهابي مدعوم من
الغربطر قد يستخدمه المسؤولونك حجه
ضد المتظاهرين
وسط ما يحدث في ايران من انفلات امنيا
ظهرت مخوفه من ان تستغل تنظيمات ارهابيه
الوضع لشنها هجمات داخليه وهو ما يتوافقوا
مع روايه السلطات الايرانيه الا ان محللين
يلاحظون عدم اتساق الهجمات الاخيره وهجمات
تنظيم داعش ويرونها حجه لتبني حمله امنيه
بردت فعل اكثر شده تعتمد على الخوف والرعب
وهو ما سيجازف به النظام وبنزلاق حركه
الاحتجاجات نحو العنف بعد ان بقيت سلمت
الى حد كبير روان حمزه العربيه